це є чистокровне свідчення абсолютно
від'ємного інтелектуального рівня не
просто радників офісу президента але й
тих хто найняв цих радників на роботу до
речі Ці радники не
декларуються радники мають занадто
багато впливу радники не будучи
офіційними особами вони чомусь ведуть
переговори і вирішують Що нам робити зі
збройними контрактами це ну для громадян
України задумайтеся це це це вже просто
перебір з маразмом який може бути в
офісі президента це ті ди ніхто але вони
чомусь вирішують все і ні за що не
відповідають ну з дипломатичної точки
зору то його зараз не просто звільняти
треба було його треба було притягати до
відповідальності і на колінах просити
вибачення у представників цих країн за
те що таке відбувається